So we're going to continue
talking today about, about DNA.
And in particular we're going to
focus today on sort of how to,
how to manipulate and use
a DNA in some applications.
And this is a huge area of,
uh, of science and technology.
Uh, you know, this, you can,
uh, it's, it's hard to, uh,
pick up a newspaper or a news magazine
without hearing some new application of
DNA technology.
So what I'm going to do is focus on sort
of a couple basic things that turn out
to be a really important
for general applications.
And then I'll talk not in too much detail
about a few applications of DNA that
you're probably familiar with to try
to give you a, a framework, uh, to,
to hang this on. And uh, this, uh,
I think chapter three
describes fairly well. Um,
the things we'll talk about today and
you've probably already noticed that
there's some material that sort of set
aside from the text and in boxes and I
encourage you to particularly look
at those boxes for this chapter.
There's one on DNA
fingerprinting for example.
That gives you a little bit more
detail about that specific, uh,
about that specific technique.
Another one on, on, uh,
production of therapeutic proteins.
I'll talk about these both a bit today,
but I encourage you to read
those for more information.
So I want to start kind of where we
left off last time we talked about the
structure of DNA,
how it works in terms of a physical
chemical model of the DNA molecules.
We talked about base pairing and
how that leaves to this process of
hybridization or very specific
matching between complimentary strands.
And we talked very superficially
about, um, about the,
the biological process
going from DNA to protein.
So the process of transcription,
RNA processing and translation
to produce a protein.
And then I ended with this
picture that, that, um,
that shows you a little bit about control
of gene expression and the important
concept that while every cell in your
body has the capability of making all the
proteins that are needed
throughout your body,
not every cell is doing
that at any given time.
Only certain genes are being expressed.
And it's the family of genes that
are being expressed in a cell.
Likewise,
the family that are not being expressed,
that determines what a cell is like,
how it functions,
what's called the phenotype of a cell.
Um,
and we will talk more about this next
week when we start talking about cells and
a little bit about cell physiology.
Uh,
but there are multiple mechanisms that
a cell can use to decide which genes it
is expressing at any one time
and which ones are not expressed.
And I showed you this
in this picture here.
And those levels of control can be
at the level of transcription. So,
and there are molecules in cells that,
uh,
give the DNA the signal that it's
time to transcribe and express a gene.
Those are called transcription factors.
We'll talk about them a bit later.
There's a interfering with RNA processing.
And I'm going to talk about that in the
next couple of slides because there's a
couple of new methods for um,
or potentially interfering
with gene expression in,
in living animals that have been
developed based on changing, uh,
interfering with DNA
transcription. And, uh,
and um,
and the ability of,
of messenger RNA to be translated and
you could interfere at these later levels
as well. For example, by, uh,
by augmenting a RNA degradation if the
messenger RNA for protein is not present
in a cell than the,
that that can't be translated
obviously in the protein can't be made.
So these two new medical therapies
that, um, that I mentioned are based on,
are interfering with the biology of RNA
and one is older than the other and the
older one is called antisense therapy.
And when you think about
a Jean or a transcript,
the messenger RNA copy of a gene,
uh,
you know that for every
sequence of a nucleic acid,
there's a complimentary sequence now
of the two complementary sequences,
one of them in codes, the gene, right?
One of them has the right sequence
of code ons to specify the amino acid
sequence of the protein. And the other
one has a complimentary sequence.
And you know,
from our discussion last time that
these two complimentary strands are not
mirror images of one another and they're
not identical, they're complimentary,
right?
They face in the opposite direction.
And you could predict the
properties of one from base pairing,
a base pairing rules of the other,
but they're not the same.
So one of the strands and codes the
protein encodes for the protein,
the other does not.
The one that does is called the sense
strand and the other one's called the
antisense strand anti meaning it's the
compliment and it will hybridize to the
sense.
So what if you knew what
the sequence of a gene was?
A gene,
let's say it's the gene for insulin.
Um,
and I'll use that one as
an example because it's a
familiar one to most people.
And you know that the protein insulin is
made only in your pancreas and certain
cells of the pancreas.
So that means those cells are
continually making messenger RNA and that
messenger RNA is being
converted into protein. Well,
what if you knew the sequence for the
Messenger Rna that made insulin and you
designed another single stranded DNA
or RNA molecule that was the exact
opposite, or the exact compliment
I should say, of that strand.
So you made somehow an antisense
Pauline nucleotide to the insulin gene
or some fraction of the insulin gene.
Well, that antisense strand
is shown here as the red
right,
and the sale is naturally making the blue
or since strand of messenger RNA for a
particular protein.
Well,
if somehow you could take your antisense
molecules that you'd made and you could
get them into cells,
then by this process of hybridization,
they would naturally
form a pair like this.
They would naturally hybridize and
form a duplex or a double stranded,
a double stranded,
a nucleic acid,
and when it's double stranded,
this gene can't be translated.
Okay?
All right.
When it's double stranded,
it can't be translated because you have
to have the single strand in order for
the transfer RNA to bind and for this
process of translation to take place.
And so what you could do then,
if you could deliver these
red colored molecules here,
is you could stop specifically
the expression of this
particular gene in these
particular cells.
All right?
Now, what are the challenges there? Well,
you've got to be able to make this stuff
and you've got to be able to make it in
large quantities.
And we'll talk about how to make nucleic
acids in large quantities a little bit
later in the lecture here and you've
also got to get it into the cell.
And it turns out that getting
large molecules like this,
particularly large charged molecules
like nucleic acids inside of cells,
it's not so easy. And we'll talk about
that a little bit later as well. In fact,
we'll talk about that concept throughout
the course because one of the big
challenges of making these sort of new
biological therapies work in people to
treat diseases,
um,
is getting the right molecules into the
right cells at the right period of time.
Now,
I gave you the example of insulin and you
probably wouldn't want to stop insulin
production, right? That might
not be a good thing to do,
but what if this is a gene that's causing
a cell to be cancerous? It was just a,
it was,
it was a gene that was causing a cell
to be malignant and to divide without
control,
for example.
Then you could imagine blocking
gene expression would be a therapy.
Okay. All right. I'm sorry.
Why you'd want to do that? Yeah. So
you wouldn't want to stop the insulin,
for example,
they get back to what you might prefer
to do is start insulin production.
And we'll talk about ways
to do that in just a minute.
So these are ways to to stop
a gene from being expressed.
And there turns out there's
lots of applications in that.
Lots of diseases result from the unwanted
expression of certain kinds of genes.
And cancer is probably the best example
of that. But there are, there are many,
a newer version of this that,
that works in a similar way,
but a different way is
called RNA interference.
And it turns out that this is a natural
mechanism that cells have. And, and it's,
it's a, it's a mechanism that they
have evolved in order to present,
prevent foreign genes from entering a
cell and being expressed in that you have
mechanisms inside your natural mechanisms
inside your cell that allow the cells
to degrade unwanted RNA sequences.
And those mechanisms are called RNA
interference. You might. Um, um,
okay.
You might've heard about
this because it's a,
it's been quite an active area of
science of science and it turns out to
activate RNA sequence,
RNA interference,
you deliver double stranded RNA and
certain double stranded RNA sequences will
cause in the cell a process of degradation
of a very specific RNA sequence.
And this involves mechanisms
that are still being
understood. Uh, but if you're a,
if you've studied some biology
or read about this, you've
heard about, um, the, uh,
the, the uh, protein complex
called dicer and dicer is a,
is an internal cellular
mechanism for degrading our rns.
And um,
you might have also heard about the uh,
risk complex or the right or
the RNA silencing a complex.
And these are the biological mechanisms
that are involved here and only shown by
sort of orange arrows on this slide.
The end result is that you can,
you can design now very specific
double stranded RNA sequences that when
delivered into sales, again,
we'll activate this process of,
of natural degradation of
an existing messenger RNA.
And of course if you
degrade the Messenger Rna,
okay
at a rapid rate,
then you'll stop expression of the cells.
Now the Nice thing about this is that the,
the,
the degradation mechanisms seem to
persist for some period of time beyond the
time at which you deliver
the double stranded RNA.
Whereas obviously this mechanism here is
only going to exist for as long as the
antisense sequence is present, right?
So this might be a longer lasting,
a more permanent form of, uh, of, uh, of,
um, elimination of the
expression of a particular gene.
Okay.
So I just wanted to introduce
those concepts because you've,
you've read about them.
We'll be talking more about about RNA
interference in particular as we go on
through the course.
The rest of the time I want to talk
about expression of genes of new genes.
So taking foreign genes,
genes that aren't naturally expressed or
might not even exist inside a cell and
putting them there and putting them
there in a way where work and by work,
meaning the gene gets expressed,
are translated into a protein.
And I'm going to start by talking about
a very specific and interesting form of
double stranded DNA called a plasmid.
And plasmids occur in nature and
plasmids turn out to be one of the most
powerful and simplest
examples of a vector,
what's called a vector for delivering,
uh, for delivering DNA into a cell.
And now the challenge is not just to
get the DNA that encodes a gene into a
cell,
the challenge is to get it into the sale
and a form where the cell can use it,
can express it and make
proteins from it. And, uh,
so the plasmid has some features
which allow it to do that. Now,
to start with the plasmid is usually shown
in the diagram. Like this is a circle.
It's a double stranded
circular piece of DNA,
meaning that the three prime five
prime ends that hang off our,
our join back together again to form
a continuous, a continuous loop.
And again, these plasmids
occurred naturally in, um,
in nature that they were
discovered, uh, particularly in,
in microorganisms have plasma to that
confer biological properties onto them.
So this particular, this
particular example of a
plasma, it has several regions.
Now in your, in your book, there's an
example of a plasmid, uh, where, uh,
where I've given you the exact sequence
of nucleotides that makes up the whole
double stranded DNA molecule. You just
get, I just give you one of those, right?
Because you could write down
the other one because you know,
the other complimentary sequence
from base pairing. Um, but uh,
one of the things about these plasmas
that makes them very useful is that their
entire base pair sequences
known. So, you know,
everywhere on this picture you could
write down exactly what the sequence of of
nucleotides are that make
up this, uh, this vector,
this region here of
this particular plasma.
It is called the Ori or
origin of replication.
And remember we talked about how DNA
replicates itself and that there are
enzymes, DNA polymerase that
bind to the double stranded DNA,
separated denature it locally and then
start the process of replication, right?
So one of the properties that you would
like a plasma to have as you'd like for
sales to be able to replicate it,
to make more copies of it.
That way you could deliver a small number
of vectors and they could amplify into
a large number of vectors.
And so having a place that the cell knows
where the cell knows how to replicate
is important. And so plasma to
have an origin of replication.
The Blue Region here is a gene,
it's a gene that's on the plasma.
In this particular gene confers
a specific biological property,
two cells that have the plasmid
and can use it properly.
And the property it
gives here is called amp,
superscript r or resistance to ampicillin.
Ampicillin is an antibiotic.
Antibiotics are chemicals,
usually small organic molecules that
will kill microorganisms like, uh,
like, uh, like bacteria. And um,
and if they,
if a cell has a gene that makes
it resistant to Ampicillin,
and that means that that micro organism
can survive being exposed to this
normally deadly chemical,
uh, without dying.
And so this is one of the,
this is one of the biological properties.
The naturally occurring properties of
plasmids is that they exist in microbial
populations and they confer
on them resistance from
toxins that would ordinarily
kill them.
So being a microorganism that got a
plasma that gave you resistance to an
antibiotic would be a good thing that
gave you resistance to something that
naturally killed cells like you and
your environment would be a good thing.
But we're going to use that.
Uh, we're going to use that
ampicillin resistance in,
in, um, in technological ways. And I'll,
I'll, I'll describe that in a minute.
And the rest of this,
this sort of beige part of the molecule
here is called the poly linker part.
And this is where,
this is the region of the plasmid where
we're going to insert the DNA that we're
interested in.
We're going to have DNA that we would
like to make lots of copies of or we're
going to have DNA that we would
like to get expressed in a cell.
And we're going to put it in this
region that's called the poly linker.
And how we do that. Uh, we'll be,
we'll be clear in a, in a few minutes,
but this poly linker is as described down
here is a site where you can clone in
jeans.
Uh,
so let's assume that we have this
plasmid cloning vector and we have some,
uh, pieces of DNA that we would
like to put into a plasmid, right,
that we would like to make copies of.
And DNA cloning or any kind of
cloning just means making copies of.
So the process of cloning DNA is taking
a few strands of DNA of a gene that
you're interested in, in making
many copies of them. That's cloning.
You'd like to make identical copies.
And this vector is going
to allow us to do this.
The first step in the process
is to take our plasmid,
which we've selected and to insert
the gene that we want into it.
Okay?
For a minute,
just assume that we can do this and I'm
going to show you how to do it on the
next slide. Uh, but,
but the first step is to take the DNA
fragments that we're interested in and put
them into this vector by basically
cutting open the double stranded DNA and
inserting the gene that we like in the,
in the region where we've cut,
then we're going to take the
newly formed vectors that now are,
uh,
recombinant.
They're combined from at least
two different sources, right?
And the sources are one,
the plasmid vector that we've picked.
And the second is these genes that
for some reason we're interested in,
and they might have come from two
completely different places from two
completely different species from
different parts of the world, right?
And they're put together in a new way,
and that's why it's
called recombinant DNA.
And then we're going to take these,
uh,
these plasmid vectors and we're going to
somehow put them in contact with cells
in such a way that the cells in jest,
the DNA and they use it.
And in this particular example here,
uh,
we're exposing these
plasmids to bacterial cells,
and that's shown in this diagram as little
colonies of bacteria that are growing
on a plate. Okay. And you've
probably seen auger plates.
If you smear a solution that's
contaminated with bacteria on it, then uh,
then that bacteria will grow on this
auger rich medium and you'll get many,
many copies of the bacteria that you've
smeared at low density onto the plate.
And that's a way of culturing
or propagating bacteria. Well,
if you do that under the situation
where you've put your plasmid into these
microorganisms,
then you're going to have little colonies
that grow many copies of the bacterial
cells.
And hopefully each one of those cells
is containing one or more of the plasma.
It's that you're interested in and
those are being copied as well.
And so what you get on the plate is many
copies of the small number of plasmids
that you've put in.
Now,
how do you find those colonies on a
plate that have the plasma that you want?
Well, well that's, that's a trick and
there are multiple ways to do that.
But one way is to allow these bacteria
to grow on a plate that is loaded with
antibiotics like ampicillin.
If this plate has ampicillin in it,
then the only cells that
wouldn't be able to grow here,
our sales that have
resistance stamp facility.
And if you selected the cells right,
then the only ones that have that
resistance to ampicillin are the ones that
successfully got your plasmid and are
using this ampicillin resistant gene.
And you could imagine strategies where
you have multiple resistance genes on a
plasmid resistance to ampicillin to
penicillin, Erythromycin for example.
And you design strategies for
separating out which, which cells are,
um, are, are carrying the plasma
that you're interested in.
But this process of using a, a, um,
biological,
um,
a biological event like resistance to
ampicillin in order to pick out the cell
population that you're interested
in is called selection.
If we grew these cells on a plate loaded
with ampicillin and we could select
cells that have ampicillin resistance,
and this process of selection in cell
culture is very important and we'll talk
about it more next day, next week. So,
so how did we put our gene fragments
into this plasma DNA in order to make
multiple copies of it or
to clone the gene? Well it,
it involves several steps.
The first step is we had to be able to
take this circular DNA and cut it to
create a site for our
new gene to be added.
And that cutting is done by uh,
by special proteins called restriction
enzymes and restriction enzymes or just a
kind of enzyme enzymes are protein
molecules that make a chemical reaction go
faster.
And the chemical reaction that
restriction enzymes do is cutting DNA.
And they do that in a very special way
and that they restriction enzymes are
able to identify a particular
sequence of bases in a gene.
There's whole families of restriction
enzymes. There are, there are hundreds,
thousands of them known now.
And each one has a specific character.
And one of the aspects of its character
is that it only binds and cuts at a
particular sequence of DNA.
And so this particular restriction
enzyme here recognizes this sequence, g,
a, t, t, c,
and when it sees that sequence in
a, in a, a double stranded DNA,
it will bind there and it will cut.
Now another property of restriction
enzymes is that they always cut the DNA.
And the same way.
In this case,
this particular restriction enzyme cuts
symmetrically like this,
but not at the same point.
It doesn't cut straight across
the double stranded DNA,
but it cuts in this
jagged fashion that is,
it cuts between the g and the AA here
and it cuts between the g and the a here.
And so when it cuts,
it leaves sticky ends or unbased paired
a single stranded regions on each end of
the part, it's cut, right?
And that's just a property
of many restriction enzymes,
not all, some cut blunt,
just right down the middle.
Most restriction enzymes
also recognize symmetric,
a symmetric, a sequences
of DNA, g, a, t, t,
C for example.
If you do the base pairing goes exactly
the same sequence backwards down here.
That's an example of a symmetric sequence
and it happens that most restriction
enzymes also recognize those spaces.
Well if you cut and you
open up a segment of DNA,
then you've left these sticky ends,
for example.
And these sticky ends are capable of
recognizing each other by the process of
hybridization,
right?
So these will naturally want to reform
and they'll want to reform to reestablish
this base pairing and so they
could be pasted back together.
And the pasting process takes advantage
of this natural process of complimentary.
So this gives you a biological
mechanism for cutting,
using restriction enzymes
and then
you denature so that it falls apart and
then you re nature so that it comes back
together.
Cutting involves a enzymes called
restriction agent and endonuclease's are
restriction enzymes which I've already
mentioned and uh, they have names,
restriction enzymes have names.
The particular one that does this function
here is called echo are one and the
names all look,
they're all italicized and their capital
letters and small letters so that they
won't be easy for you to understand.
Uh, but they, but they are,
if you know the nomenclature,
easy to understand this,
this restriction enzyme was
founded in a natural source.
It was found in a micro
organism called ECO lie.
And the first three letters
of e coli or e, s c o.
So Echo it was found in strain
are a particular strain of e coli.
And it was the first
one found echo are one.
And so there's a nomenclature that's
evolved for this and now we know so much
about these,
they've turned out to be so useful
in biotechnology that there are whole
catalogs that you can go to and buy
restriction enzymes and you can look up in
the catalog. What are the properties
of this restriction enzyme?
What base sequence does it recognize?
How does it cut,
what concentration do I
need to use to achieve that?
And so if you have a plasmid where
you know all the base pairings,
then you could go through that plasmid
and say, I want to cut it right here.
What restriction enzyme will do that?
Or You could ask the question,
I have this restriction enzyme at what
regions on this plasmid Willick cut,
right?
The pasting back together occurs
partly naturally by this process of
hybridization,
but hybridization only
reestablishes the base pairing.
You know that these molecules are also
linked in another way, right? Bad.
The phosphate bonds that connect the
three prime in the five prime carbons of
adjacent nucleotides.
And that doesn't heal naturally,
but can be reformed by other
enzymes called light gazes,
like aces reestablished
the phosphate bonds.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
how would I put in a gene that I'm
interested in into a plasmid? Well,
the first,
uh,
the first step would be to cut open the
plasmid with a particular restriction
enzyme.
And then what if I take
that same restriction enzyme
and I cut up the DNA that
I'm interested in?
If I cut both the plasmid and my DNA
of interest with the same restriction
enzyme, I'm going to end up with the same
sticky ends on both molecules. Right?
And so now if I put them in
contact with one another,
the plasma that's been
opened and fragments of the
DNA special fragments that
I've produced with the
same restriction enzyme,
they'll have the same sticky ends.
They will naturally
hybridize with one another.
I apply ligase and I've got
the plasma that I have before,
but now with my Jean
colored green here inserted.
Right.
Yeah,
that's a really good question
because if I open this up,
why wouldn't it just reform with itself?
Why would it want to have this in here?
And, and the answer is it will
want to reform with itself.
And if I have these in solution,
then how many reform with itself and
how many reform with the molecule I'm
interested probably depends on the
relative concentrations of both in the
solution and what conditions I have at at.
So it's a statistical process.
Some are going to reform and some are
going to reform with the gene in and some
are probably aren't gonna reseal it all
under the conditions that I've used.
Right.
So not every plasmid in your test tube
is going to have the right gene inserted
in the right way.
Um,
so one way that you can look for that
gene that you want is by making the cut in
your plasmid
inside of a gene that encodes for
some property like resistance to an
antibiotic.
If this reforms,
so the plasmid reform
back to its native state,
that resistance will be recovered.
So bacteria that get an unloaded
plasmid are going to have resistance to
antibiotics.
If your gene goes in,
you've interrupted the gene for antibiotic
resistance and those new organisms
aren't going to be resistant
to antibiotic anymore.
And so you could use sort of negative
selection in order to find the ones that
you want.
I don't know if that makes sense or not,
but yeah,
so,
so some do,
but there's an advantage to having the
sticky end there and that you can put
things back on.
But there are also methods to chemically
produce a sticky end where you can take
blunt ends and you can add specific
nucleotides onto one of the,
one of the DNA chains by either doing
chemistry on the three prime or the five
prime end and create your own sticky hand.
So sometimes a blunt cut is useful if
you want to sort of grow a sticky end of
your choice on it.
And,
and you're starting to see that there's
all different ways that one could take
advantage of this fairly simple
process of cutting and pasting. And,
and that's why, um, molecular biology,
one of the reasons why it's turned
out to be such a powerful tool.
Because if you can think creatively,
you can find all different ways to
using these very simple principles to
recombine molecules to make
unique new DNA sequences,
right?
Where does the DNA sequence come from?
I want to spend a little time talking
about that and let's say we've got a human
gene that we want to make and let's say
it's the human gene for insulin that we
want to produce now.
And so all the cells in your body
have the gene for insulin in them,
only cells in the pancreas. Some cells
in the pancreas are making insulin.
So one way I could try
to find the gene for, uh,
for human insulin is to take any
cells from, from any of us skin cells,
let's say. And I could identify where
on the Chromosomal DNA that, um,
that, um, insulin is likely to occur.
And I could cut that up into fragments
and I could search in these fragments to
try to find the one that has a
insulin, the insulin gene on it. Now,
the problem with that is a problem I
mentioned before that most human genes are
not just a straight sequence
from beginning to end of
the protein that you're
interested in.
There are in coding regions called
Exxon's and those are interrupted by
noncoding regions called introns.
And if I cut up just
DNA from the chromosome,
what's called Genomic
Dna, uh, then I'm gonna,
then I'm going to have both Exxon's
and introns within the fragments that I
create. That might be a
good way to do it, but,
but it's going to be more of a
challenge, right? Because you might,
you're going to have a lot of these non
coding sequences that are in the way and
alternate way is to go to the cell
that's making the protein that you want.
And if it's making the protein you want,
it must be producing messenger
RNA with that gene on it.
And that messenger RNA that's being
used has already gone through the RNA
splicing mechanism. And so the
introns have already been removed.
And if I could isolate that messenger
Rna Messenger RNA is just a copy of the
DNA from which it came,
right?
So if I could do the process
of reverse transcription,
that is instead of transcription,
which goes from DNA to RNA,
if I could go backwards from RNA to DNA,
I could recover a DNA version of
the gene that I'm interested in.
And it turns out that we can do that
now because we have an enzyme called
reverse transcriptase,
which is able to take single
stranded a messenger RNA and make uh,
and make DNA out of it.
Now you've heard about reverse
transcriptase someplace before, right?
Anybody heard of reverse transfer?
HIV?
HIV is a natural virus that, that,
that contains an enzyme in it.
Why does it contain reverse
transcriptase in it?
Because HIV is an RNA virus
and if it enters your cell,
the only way it can replicate it can
put its DNA into your cells is by first
making DNA out of its RNA genome.
We're going to talk more about
this later. Uh, but um, so,
so reverse transcriptase is a
naturally occurring protein.
It has a biological function.
And HIV,
but we can use it for a technical logical
function here by going backwards on
the biological path from messenger
RNA to uh, to, uh, to DNA.
Now, DNA that's produced this way is not
called Genomic Dna because this doesn't
match the, it does not match the DNA in
your genome on your chromosomes, right?
The introns are gone.
Now it's called CDNA or complementary
DNA to indicate that it's a copy,
a complimentary copy of the Messenger Rna.
But this is a much more
efficient way to get,
to get a DNA for a gene that you're
interested in for a couple of reasons.
One is the processing has already been
done, so the introns are already out,
so you don't have to figure out what's
the Exxon and what's the in Tron.
It's already done for you. Plus,
if you're looking for insulin,
okay,
if you're looking for
the gene for insulin,
you're going to cells that
are making it already.
They have abundant messenger RNA,
so it's much easier to
separate out and identify the,
the gene that you're interested in.
You're not fishing through a whole
chromosome in order to find what you want,
but you're going to a cell
that's already enriched in it.
Does that make sense?
I want to talk about one other technique
and then I'm going to give you some
examples about how to, how to use these
in the last in the last few minutes,
but the,
the,
the technique I want to talk about is
one called polymerase chain reaction and
this is another way to clone or make
many copies of a gene of interest. Now,
one of the big advantages of plasmids I
already mentioned is that you can take
this plasmid and a plasmid is a,
is you could think of it as a highly
tuned machine for copying itself,
right? A plasmid is a highly tuned
machine for making copies of itself.
You take that plasma and you put
it in the right micro organism,
you're going to make many,
many copies of that plasmid and we're
cloning a gene of interest to us by sort
of hijacking that biological mechanism
by putting our gene on this plasmid.
And so our gene gets copied many times
as the plasma. It gets copied many times.
So that's a way of cloning DNA.
Here's a note that that's a biological
way of cloning it and we're using
biological mechanisms
and we're growing cells.
Yeah.
In order to accomplish it. Here's a way
that you can do it in a test tube, uh,
without using any cells by this process
called polymerase chain reaction.
And I'll describe how it works here you
have a fragment of some kind of DNA that
you would like to, that you would
like to clone or make many copies of.
Yeah.
Now in general, these
are small fragments, uh,
but they're not whole genomes,
but there's some small piece of DNA,
maybe the size of a,
of a protein,
and you put this Chromosomal Dna or this
DNA that you're interested in double
stranded into a test tube.
And you do that together with
primers and with nucleotides.
Because if you're going to synthesize DNA,
you need the raw material of DNA,
right?
You need the individual nucleotides and
you add a special DNA polymerase called
Taq polymerase.
And Tech Polymerase is polymerase.
That was identified a DNA polymerase
that was identified from an organism that
lives in regions of the earth,
where there that are,
they're constantly at high temperature.
Tack stands for Thermos. Aquatic is,
it's a marine microorganism that near
lives near these hydrothermal events in
the bottom of the sea.
And they live under very high
temperatures and pressures all the time.
And so their enzymes are tuned.
Unlike our enzymes,
which are tuned for working most
efficiently at 37 degrees centigrade,
tack is used to living
at 90 degrees centigrade.
And so it's enzymes operate most
efficiently at this elevated temperature.
Um,
and so you take advantage of that.
You put it in a test tube together with
nucleotides and primers and your DNA,
and now you start a process,
a cyclical process where the first step
in the process is denaturing the DNA.
And you can do that by gently
adding heat and making it basic.
But you make the two DNA strands separate
when they separate the primers that
you've added automatically bind right
through the process of hybridization.
And then you turn up the temperature to
the optimum per taq polymerase and DNA
synthesis starts.
That polymerase starts a process of
replication of your DNA sequences.
So you, you, uh, first separated your DNA,
let the primers bind,
then turn on the enzyme and it
makes copies of each one of these.
You then denature again,
each one of these strands get separated.
Primers bind, turn on the
polymerase. A new strand is made.
And if you repeatedly go through this
cycle of denaturing synthesizing,
denaturing synthesizing, you'll
get many, many copies of DNA.
The number of copies you get depends on
how many times you do the cycling, right?
And you'll get, if you have, if you
start with, if you start with only one,
you know,
two pieces of DNA,
then you'll get a two to the
nth fragments after end cycles.
Because each cycle you're producing,
you're doubling the number.
This has turned out to be a very powerful
technique because it's relatively
rapid.
It's totally synthetic.
There's no microorganism involved in
making the, making the, making the,
uh, um, uh, DNA for you. Uh,
so you can do it very rapidly in a
laboratory and fairly inexpensively now.
And it's really been a powerful
tool in, in, um, in, uh,
molecular biology because I might
have a very small copy of a,
of a gene that I'm interested in and I
can make enough copies that I can start
to do something else with it.
All right.
You can also use PCR to identify specific
genes that are present in a biological
sample. So you can use PA
PCR for fingerprinting as
well for looking in a, in a,
in a, some unknown fluid, for example,
is a gene that I'm interested in there.
And you could use PCR to do that
because if you amplify a gene in PCR,
that gene had to be
present from the beginning.
Right?
Well, let's talk about some
mechanisms for using this.
And I'll start with a simple example
of how one can detect a gene in a,
in a, um, in a fluid, in a
blood sample, for example,
where that gene is unknown.
And this takes advantage of the very
specific properties of a restriction
enzymes. And this particular example
involves the gene for sickle cell anemia.
Sickle cell anemia is a
disease that affects a subset
of the population and it's
a single gene defect.
And we know exactly where the the
genetic defect is in sickle cell.
It's on the gene for hemoglobin.
And the hemoglobin that that you produce
if you have sickle cell anemia is not
quite right because
there's one, uh, a meat.
There's one based difference if you,
um,
if you have normal hemoglobin, you
have this sequence here, CCT g, a,
G, G, g. In sickle hemoglobin you have,
I sequenced, it's only slightly
different within the gene CCT, g,
T, G, G, a, g. So there's a, there's a
thei mean that substituted for an Alanine.
And that results in making
hemoglobin that's not quite right.
That doesn't function in the
same way as as, uh, as uh,
the normal hemoglobin gene does.
So how could I identify in a chromosomal
DNA sample whether the sickle gene is
present? But one way you could do
it is by saying, if, if I have this,
if I have this one base pair difference,
then this sequence is going to be cut
by a specific restriction enzyme that
recognizes the sequence
CT, g, a, G, G, a, right?
And that restriction enzyme,
there is a restriction enzyme
that does that and has MST three.
If I took this same restriction enzyme
and tried to cut the chromosome ml DNA of
a sickle patient,
it wouldn't cut at that point
because the wrong sequence is there.
So here's how can I, how
can I find that, right?
Here's a difference between,
uh,
between normal hemoglobin and
sickle hemoglobin. I can make a,
I can see a chemical difference. I can
exploit it. How can I find it? Well,
the way to find it is by
using a process called, uh,
called electrophoresis
and southern blotting and
electrophoresis is described in
the chapter here. I'll just describe
it briefly. If you have DNA fragments.
So this is DNA that you've cut up into
fragments using restriction enzymes,
for example. You load them into the
top of a Gel and the Gel is, uh,
is, uh, in this case it's
a synthetic polymer gel,
but it looks very much like Jello. And
I'm sure some of you have, have, uh,
have dealt with, uh, electrophoresis
gels in the past and it's really just a,
a slab of something like Jello where
you can put a sample at one end of the
Jello,
your sample of fragmented DNA.
Now you apply electrical charge
across that Jello because it's a gel.
Electricity is going to move through
the jail because they're ions in it the
same way for the same reason. You
don't drop a, uh, a, uh, uh, um,
electrical device into the bathtub,
uh,
because charge moves through
water that has ions in it, right?
Charge is going to move through this
gel and DNA is charged, right? It's,
it's loaded with
phosphates, which are, uh,
which are negatively charged and they're
going to move from a negative pole to a
positive pole. And so they're
gonna move through this Gel. Well,
if you've created fragments here and
they're fragments of different size,
the small ones are going to
move faster than the big ones.
And so the DNA is going to get spread out
on this gel according to size with the
small ones going farther
and the short and the,
and the large ones not going as far.
So if I can run the Gel for some period
of time, run the electrical fields,
spread it out,
and now if I can stay in in some way,
if I can somehow label the DNA seq
fragments that I'm interested in,
I could find out where those fragments
are on this gel and I would be able to
predict their size because
how far they moved,
dependent on how big they were.
So how would I,
how would I label this
DNA? Well, the, the,
the best way to label this DNA is by
designing probes or labels that hybridized
with specific sequences that
you're interested in, right?
So this label is DNA that might be made
radioactive or made fluorescence and it
has a base pair sequence that is from
some other region of the gene that you're
interested in.
And so it's only going to
bind to fragments that contain
that piece of the gene,
right?
And it will make those
visible to you in some way.
So you can see where your gene traveled.
Now,
something similar to this as the basis
of DNA fingerprinting that's described in
one of the boxes in your book. In this
specific example, what are we going to do?
We're going to take a chromosomal DNA,
we're going to digest it
with this restriction enzyme.
We're going to put it in this tube and
run it on a gel and we're going to see
what results down here
in a normal cell DNA.
That DNA in the normal cell, this DNA
gets cut by the restriction enzyme.
So the sickle gene ends up or so the
hemoglobin gene ends up in two pieces.
One that's 0.2 kilo bases long and
one that's 1.1 kilo bases long.
Kilobases a thousand base basis.
And so when I look for it here,
I'm going to see two pieces.
One that's uh,
nearly the same length and
one that's much shorter.
If this was a sickle patient, so they
didn't, so they had this gene instead,
it wouldn't get cut.
And when I went to look for that
presence of that gene on this gel,
it would appear as one large segment
instead of a large one in the smaller one.
And so the absence of this smaller region
tells you that this sample came from a
sickle patient.
Right?
And so you can imagine other ways of
doing this or why is it doing the same
thing in different ways,
but it takes advantage of the
specificity of the restriction enzymes,
the fact that we know what
the gene sequence is that
we're looking for and using
this,
uh,
this technological process
of electrophoresis to
identify changes that we
predict.
That's, yeah, go ahead.
Yeah. This is just one particular
example of how to, how to do it,
but you could imagine.
So you have to identify something
that's unique about it and then design a
method for identifying that unique thing.
And here,
the unique thing was that there's
a restriction site inside that is,
it's is present in normal
DNA and not present in, um,
in sickle DNA. But if you could
identify some other change,
you could do it as well.
MMM.
Another example of,
of using this techniques is to
produce therapeutic proteins from,
from cloned DNA. And I'm, I'm
going to describe this one.
This will probably be the, the, um, uh,
the last example I have time for and I'll,
so I'll go through the rest of
them quickly in the next lecture.
But here for example,
the idea is to make many copies of a
protein for use as a pharmaceutical.
So now here's an example where
we'd like to make insulin.
We're having the insulin gene would be
useful if we could take the insulin gene
and make many copies of the
insulin protein. That would
be a very useful thing.
And it turns out that there's lots of
proteins that have value as therapeutics
and there's a list of them here and some
of them you'll recognize a wreath wrote
poetry in, uh, commonly called HIPO.
And its function is to treat
anemia because it stimulates
blood cell production.
You might think that its
function is to make you a more,
a better cyclist, but that's
not its only function. Uh,
it's used to treat people that have,
you've heard about HIPO and
blood doping.
Everybody's tired something.
Yes. Yeah. Uh, but it,
but it's a therapeutic protein as well
and very useful for patients with the
anemia. Um, so how do you make
many copies of a cloned DNA? Well,
one way is to do just exactly what we
talked about before. Take a plasmid,
cut it open, insert a gene
that we want into the plasmid,
and then put that plasmid in a host
cell and let the host replicated.
Now in this case, the host, you,
you want the host not only
to replicate all the DNA,
you want it also to express the gene.
You're not just trying to clone the DNA,
you're trying to also clone or make many
copies of the protein. And so that's a,
that's a slightly different thing,
right?
Because we want not only
for the cell to be able to,
okay,
synthesize the DNA.
You want it to be able to express
the protein off the DNA as well.
And so that requires
designed at a different,
not only does it have to have an origin
of replication which works so that you
can synthesize the DNA. The gene has to
be inserted together with a promoter,
and that promoter is a sequence,
a DNA sequence that the host will
recognize as a signal to transcribe and
translate this protein.
We'll talk more about promoters
as they go on. For now,
let's just assume that we have a promoter
that works in this particular cell.
The promoter in this case
is called the Lac promoter.
And normally in a micro organisms that
lac promoter is used to produce a gene
called, um, called Lac z,
which makes a protein called Beta
Galax societies Beta galactus sideways.
What we're going to do is
take this plasmid with its
promoter gene construct in
it and,
and engineer it to take out the LAC z
gene leaving in the promoter and putting
in the protein that we want the,
the gene for the protein that we want.
In this case, it says it's a GCSF, but
it could also be insulin. For example.
Now, when we put insulin in this
place behind the right promoter,
the cell thinks that it still
has the Lac z gene present,
which it needs for its metabolism.
And so it's going to express this gene,
but you've put a foreign gene in
the place of the natural gene.
And so the foreign gene
gets expressed instead,
in this case GCSF or it could be insulin.
And now if I take this cell and I
grow it under the right conditions,
that is under conditions in which the
cell would normally express the Lac z
gene,
it's going to express our
gene instead and presumably,
hopefully make large cop
in large quantities of it.
So this was a process that was perfected
on an industrial scale by the company
Genentech in California
in the, uh, in the 1970s,
the first therapeutic protein that was
produced was insulin to treat diabetes.
Before that,
diabetics have been treated with insulin
that came from a different source,
usually from pigs so far by harvesting
and purifying a insulin from pig
pancreas. And now most diabetics
take human insulin made,
uh, made not in humans, uh,
but made in a micro organisms that
are growing, uh, in, uh, in um, uh,
manufacturing facility.
That is a way of putting a clone gene
into a microorganism and then using that
microorganism has sort of
a factory for the protein.
You could do the same thing in
mammals. And here's one, uh,
one quick example of that using
a different kind of a vector,
but inserting a gene into,
uh,
into the fertilized egg of a mammal.
In this case,
a sheep and the biology of this is more
complicated than what I described before,
but you can inject this DNA into a
egg of a sheep and then implant that
fertilized egg with the foreign DNA
that's been micro injected into it,
into a foster mother.
If that leads to the birth of a,
of a,
of a young sheep, hopefully that
she has this gene encoded in.
It's a genome now and it will
express the protein that you wanted.
A one example of the way people have
used this is that they've taken the gene
that ordinarily produces a milk protein
and they put a gene like the insulin
gene in place of the milk protein,
but behind the promoter that that
is used to produce milk proteins.
So this gene is going to be turned on
in the sheep when it makes milk under
conditions where it makes milk. And if
the sheep grows up in the right way,
and people have shown that this will work,
you can milk the sheep,
the sheep has milk, the milk
has insulin in it, right?
So here's an example of
using a large animal by, by,
by inserting the gene
that you're interested in,
you can make this animal into a factory
for the kind of protein that you would
like to make.
So I'll finish talking about these
examples at the beginning of lecture on
Tuesday.
I'll see you this afternoon in a section.